hi guys it's Nika here and today we are
going to practice yoga for pregnancy
today we have a very special guest
Carrie Carrie is in her third trimester
and she's been staying really accessed
throughout the pregnancy what have you
been doing Carrie I have been running a
lot before pregnancy so I continue doing
that until I feel like my body needs
more of a stretching and breathing sort
of element so I've actually inserted
yoga into my practice as well wonderful
all right so today we are going to
practice a very simple yoga sequence
that you can do in any trimester this
specific modification will be for a
third trimester of your pregnancy all
right so let's get started so before we
get started just make sure that whenever
something doesn't feel right
your other fries are maybe feeling a
little bit dizzy just back off go back
to your child's clothes or the resting
foods right and make sure you are not
overheating you buddy as well
pregnancy is a beautiful time when you
really have a chance to tune into your
body your intuition is really at a high
level so just do whatever feels right
and back off any time doesn't something
doesn't feel right okay all right we'll
get started you're going to sit
comfortably and now it's really good if
you have flow or a bolster so just put
it behind your underneath your back yes
just to have extra support just cross
your legs and you travel way comfortable
bring your hands and your knees
close your eyes make sure your back is
straight listen here we're going to
bring one common your tummy and add a
palm on your chest and as you breathe
deeply through your nose
you're going to connect with your body
and with your baby just inhale deeply
through your nose and gently breathe out
through your mouth
again inhale GDP through your nose and
exhale out through your Mall one two
time inhale deeply and exhale out go
back to normal greedy stay here for a
moment and join that special connection
maybe take a moment to acknowledge your
body so many beautiful changes that's
been happening throughout the month
[Music]
one more deep breath in gently explore
[Music]
slow the open your eyes please your hand
and it will start with Turnbull
stretches bring your left hand down on
the ground right hand reaching all the
way up you're going to stretch gently to
the side inhale lift up and it's change
the other side right thumb goes down and
last and do that gentle stretch keep
rereading three inner inhale let's lift
up again and as you exhale you from here
we are going to release our knees and
we'll come down on our all for I can
release the pillow to the side okay to
the fun of your mat times will be
underneath your shoulder knees below
your hips knees slightly wider in line
okay great from here we're going to go
into head and house stretch you're going
to arch your back into the cow position
gently bring your chin to the chest and
we're going to go into a very gentle how
this just slightly choking you're always
not always tripping not be inhale here
and exhale down and again into
exhale down during the pregnancy they
might be uncomfortable especially lower
back again inhale but then to get a lot
of fat phase and this is a really great
easy way to relieve this pain or
uncovered comfort and one the time
inhale one of you add just the our cubic
and you leave going to your table
through top from here let's send our
left like this stretch our last not good
just maybe spoil it it's the back and
front doors this stretch it a little bit
and you can if you can find a balance
kind of lifting your left leg up a
little bit just lift it up and down and
again lift it up
and down one the time lift it up and
yeah and release you knee down on the
ground and repeat on the other side
right like stretching out again maybe
doing a little bit from side and back
just ease your problem nice stretch add
some here I lift your right leg up
inhale and exhale bow and again inhale
up and exhale down
one with an inhale and exhale down
good release your knees to the ground
from here we're going to go to modify it
sounds like plank pose keep your left
knee down on the ground
extend your right leg to the side and
from your slowly radius of all the way
on your left hand right hand goes up
look do with your right palm or easy
side plank pose this looks to was
feeling 3d P one more and as you exhale
gently release back to this manager
let's change the side right knee goes
down laughs like expense to the back
okay try to have your knee and your palm
in one line left hand goes down we do
the side open
receipt silica foods you come and find a
balance if not look to the side is fine
and then slowly pity all the way down to
the center good from here
let's lift all the way up into your easy
downward dog again you can have your
knees bent here you can just pull your
feet in one place trying to lift your
hips up and roll the shoulders down just
again stretching your whole body keep
breathing and from here you're going to
gently open up a happen inhale and bring
your left leg all the way up slowly lift
it up stretch keep your hips wet and
then slowly really now let's change the
other side right leg is up in this
warming up inhale stretch and then
slowly it would be feel like that I'm
going to go for an easy childhood just
bring your knees as wide as you can
windows gently come down again release
any tension in your lower back sometimes
in those big grades even put a pillow in
front of you or a bolster for extra
support
leave your wrist
[Music]
click one more deep breath in exhale out
and the next inhale let's lift one more
time into you're down with breaking down
a rule it all yeah okay nice easy down
order again having a seat
and then I'll do inhaled and a slowly
start walking so is the fun of our math
bringing the feet slightly wider towards
the edges of the mat and then slowly can
keep your knees Bend you can hold your
hands away from set aside here if you
want to can stretch your knees see how
that feels for the EE bad breath just
remember to keep your legs apart to
create an extra space for the tummy
stretch here exhale out and then slowly
with your hands bring your palms
together we're going to lower your hips
in an easy Chapel okay normally your
travel needs up together but you're
gonna again feel the strenght of our
like here within the bar good inhale
lift up open your chest and as you
exhale one with time let's get down into
easy wide leg chest inhale again all the
way up open and as you exhale go down
okay let me close each one if I mean
he'll open up exhale go down staying
here for to brush Union hair lift all
the way up exhale release your hands
will try to balance a little bit less
like it straight
let's try to bring the right foot on top
of your left in a tie okay now balancing
is be quite challenging during pregnancy
especially is very good speaker so see
how far you can go is you can go a
little higher that's fine
palms on your chest or again on your
belly
three deep III uh notes here
strengthening the ankles and overall
balance one my breath slowly would
change the side right leg goes down left
foot on your inner tiny even higher and
palms on your belly keep your eyes open
and your back straight breathe
and exhale oh yeah slowly release from
here let's inhale all the way as he'll
release your pump your chest and we'll
try to take a long step back into our
war you want to okay so make sure you
have to spread forward with inhale let's
bring our hands all the way up nicely
square hip again building up strengthen
your leg then you'll need the strength
during your leisure later on three
eating hey let's lift all the way as you
exhale again go down deep inhale lift up
and as you exhale go deeper one with an
inhale lift up as you exhale let's
expand your hands to the side into
warrior two
let me right above your ankle chest
facing to the side and hands open
reaching and again let's move we hands
all the way up inhale as you exhale
release down inhale lift and exhale down
nice stretch inhale as you exhale down
hold it and breathe here four three two
and one in hello one more time as you
exhale bend your left knee left elbow
goes down on top of your height right
hand is reaching although gentle twist
in your spine and easy supported side
angle pose looking up towards your right
palm breathing deeply me and I
stretching your legs not a two and one
with inhale let's lift all the way up
again into your warrior two gentle
stretch really feeling it in your legs
and then one more time up pointing the
feet forward and we're going to go to
easy goddess both palms together be
slightly pointing outward and go down
and again inhale up open up your chest
and exhale gently down good ii hello
and exhale down inhale up exhale down
one more inhale and as you exhale palms
on your chest or maybe on your belly
hold and breathe four three two and one
II hill all the way exhale it really is
beginning to warrior two reach inhale up
exhale let's go back warrior one yes
inhale again all the way and as you
exhale try to scoot your lace a little
bit to the side drop your right knee
down and you're going to slowly go down
bring the left leg to the back get from
here down into your down it down you're
doing two in two stages from here I'm
going to bring you right leg forward
again slightly to the side you can
support within me if you have to if not
gently into your warrior one
the whole sequence on the other side say
nice for you one all gives a gentle
highlight for you in hey let's lift and
exhale down inhale up and exhale down
make sure your knees right above your
ankle inhale and exhale down one more
time up and then release your hands to
the sides warrior two
you had one is I'm inhale hands up
exhale hands to the side work with your
breath always exhale down again inhale
up and exhale down hold it for three
open your chest nicely too
and one inhaler as you exhale dried form
goes on top of your right side left hand
reaching up with me child easy side
angle pose of opening your legs in a
time three jacks another two and and
from here with the inhale lift all of it
and point your feet forward or go to
easy go-to spots feet slightly outwards
and go down in the middle good inhale up
open your chest and exhale gently down
see how far you can go
inhale again and exhale down one more
time inhale up and as you exhale hold it
again maybe palms on your tummy creating
dc2 and inhale lift up exhale warrior
two extend your hands inhale lift up
exhale forward into warrior one good one
more time inhale up and then slowly
bring your right foot slightly outwards
um we'll go forward
we need to the back edge into you're
down with them
creepy please stay here let's sit here
come is down it though you're gonna
again just drop your knees down as wet
as you can into an easy childhood
making sure that selfies with the belly
releasing any tension your lower back
free gently allowing the hips go
one more and slowly walk your palms
through your body with ease now gently
push yourself up and we're going to
expand our like pull it into the sides
with some easy stretches okay from here
again if you want so you can take a flow
and put on the clothes to just three of
extra four right just at the edge of
this Luca with inhale as bring your
hands all the way and as you exhale just
fold with your left like you can do it
slightly from the side again see how you
tell me feel right you don't want to
over stretch here pregnant moms tend to
be really really flexible because the
relaxing the hormones being released is
a stickety right one more time machine
shall lift left
I'm good exhale again you can do it from
this side low open up yeah Kerri
[Music]
one minute I'm in jail and as you exhale
you're going to go into that wide leg
forward bend again slide your hand
forward and fall on your bra I'm going
up feels good
[Music]
one more inhale lift up as you exhale
release your hands to the side you're
going to bring the feet together okay is
the easy cobblers pose or a butterfly
pose just keep your feet together and
allow your hips to open keeping your
back straight reading for the nose
[Music]
turn please hello this is a very easy
sequence and you can repeat it a few
times before you go into your relaxation
in real shavasana and we're going to
show you a modified shavasana for
pregnant moms
you should always lie down on your side
not on your back some ones are fine on
the bag especially in the beginning of
the pregnancy but it was the end it's
always better to stay safe and be on
your side all right so what are you
going to do you're going to release your
leg and you're going to need some
pillows or maybe bolsters right so
you're going to need one for your head
one for in between your leg and one for
your conference I'm going to suggest
carry alright so one for your pad right
to be comfy alright one underneath the
tummy okay and one pillow between your
legs or a bolster all right and then
there you go that feel modified
shavasana where you can just be like
this close your eyes again it can bring
your palms on your tummy on one common -
tell me just connecting with your baby
slowly relaxing your body
[Music]
it's really important to always connect
with your breath try to slow it down a
lot of times when we are pregnant with
you all these feelings of anxiety or
fear because we don't know how the labor
is going to go and generally don't know
what's going to happen to just any time
that sort of anxiety creeps and try to
go back to your bra read gently and know
that everything is going to be fine
this modified savasana is really
relaxing it's a great pose to actually
use while you're sleeping okay so that's
it that's all really really simple
sequence we're going to after that
you're gonna sit up to sit on the mat
and we are done
there you go guys very simple yoga
routine they can practice during your
pregnancy in any trimester thank you so
much for joining us today I hope it felt
good and all the best with the delivery
and it was a little baby girl
thank you so much for watching hope you
enjoyed this video do share it with your
pregnant mom friend and also leave us a
comment below and tell us how you
enjoyed it okay don't forget to check
our postnatal video leave us a thumbs up
and I'll see you next time bye